[Music]
an influencer prank news submitted by
pube fetish a youtuber tricked a
youtuber tricked influencers into
promoting pieces of gravel what they
pretend it was like gemstones or
something I have no idea like it's a
brand deal okay so this youtuber named
Josh Peters he tricks so him and his
friend his magician friend named Archie
magicians are so weird they're I don't
know is the whole culture but they did
I'm gonna tell you but their rules so we
can get what kind of person it is sure
so they sent out 40 boxes to British
influencers pretty much tricking them
into thinking that this was sent from
the National Space Center and they sent
them pieces in the wrong rocks waiting
the 50th anniversary of the moon landing
I believe it too they need to go to the
moon that's not even a good troll
he's the magician no he's he's a
youtuber and this is like what he sent
out so he sent it out with like an
actual little no soul piece of gravel
but I'm like how did you get that if
your country didn't even go to the moon
yeah but so I think what are you trying
to do is you trying to tease that out so
you have logic and he's like how many of
these influencers actually do the
research before they probably think yeah
because he's probably trying to make a
point where like a lot of these
influencers whatever free thing they get
in the mail they're just promoting it
they just make the story no matter what
so I think he's trolling those Space
Center look with the attacks the letter
has a long way the little fakes to that
little yeah let me show you and also
this it came with this like pretty like
it had like a serial number that looks
legit made that me neither
that's something I would have felt for
it I don't know if I would have promoted
it but I wasn't like oh [ __ ] that's
Bukit that maybe I would have been like
a thank you
well you got to get paid first right
we're on the second stage so he probably
reached out to the like lower level like
Instagram people's I'll show you a video
clip that you posted on Twitter that's
[ __ ] up like goal accounts than me
that isn't being robbed oh my god
this is genuinely the most awesome gift
ever at the moon landing oh we the
National Space Center slices since your
very own pieces no she's just reading it
I mean that's just like unboxing though
congratulations you are now proud owner
I'll pass the me proud owner of the
thing we do have one tool to them you
own some moon I would have fell for it
cheers guys yeah but now we get to call
them dumb cuz it wasn't us it didn't
happen to us so we gonna be like you
would never fall for it I think this is
the same thing as it's just the Nigerian
like print scandals but for influencers
you know a lot of people they go like oh
yeah if you send me
okay buy this off me and if you send me
$100 I'll save you ten thousand dollars
and then like not even close to that
they just sent them a thing and they
didn't have to give anything up they
were just happy yeah yeah but the
National Space Center I don't even know
if that's real and I just sounds fake
you know it's a real place closed wrote
they have a motive just just imagine
being them you get a piece of mail and
it's like it says like since you have a
hundred thousand Twitter followers or
whatever they have we were giving you a
piece of the Moon so you can share it
and tell people that you have a piece of
the Moon well not first because you are
an influencer so what would you think
when I was first on YouTube and like
let's say I'm in 2010 when or something
and YouTube reached out and it was like
hey you reached 100,000
we want to send you a plaque I was
already like what kind of [ __ ]
Nigerian prince scandal is this [ __ ]
right I'm already just skeptical you
know I have to like call like four
people hey is this thing real asking you
for anything you could give them a
[ __ ] random address or not ask me if
I'm already skeptical so I just I'm just
like why does you two want to give me a
plaque and then I confirm the five
people and I'm like oh so you're saying
when you vlog your life do you guys do
daily vlogging mm-hmm tell me you never
probably - part of your life were like
if you would receive something that
looked really legit and dope you
wouldn't put it in your blog after I did
my research you would not have
researched it you know that you know
maybe because I've a [ __ ] about the moon
oh I have your back on this one good so
he wouldn't do it because he's lazy as
[ __ ]
thank you he doesn't even open his
packages I have him I have your back is
immediately followed by he's lazy made
his point yeah I want in my mail once
every three months uh you open it I open
his mail okay she opened my mail and
that puts it on my desk I would have
three money things people send him to
promote like you know how many presents
you guys have given them that are still
sitting on his bed no I've seen it on
his how many times have I been duped
though you probably you probably already
have one of those moving rocks in your
household no you know I don't blame them
for opening cuz like you know as
vloggers or people that like you know we
share a life on social media no matter
what it is if I think it's something so
cool that I'm down to share it with it
does I don't need to vet everything I
don't know I don't blame you and almost
under some prank [ __ ] then it's not
you're too lazy to do I think a better
prank would be let's say you you have
moon rocks right and then these moon
rocks have like healing properties or
whatever and then you want to you want
that to be sold to - or whatever so I do
promote it as like yeah yeah so so I
give you a brand deal and I'll be like
yo sell these moon rocks for me and then
you do a promo you give them funny ass
[ __ ] talking points yeah
that's a good [ __ ] control right yeah
it's like dead sea salt but if you're
gonna make people look like fools like
really make them look this one's more
budget-friendly cuz you don't have to
pay them I know yeah no one got hurt in
the process
yeah it's a silly hoo-hoo ha and
everyone that was involved he's saying
that no one has gotten butthurt about it
and everyone's just laughing like ah you
got me man but okay so the way that they
were able to narrow it down was because
the Space Center actually hit up one of
the influencers on Instagram and they
sent them his message that says hi Jack
thanks for tagging us in your story
however we don't believe this moon rock
has come from us at the National Space
Center this is not our official
compliment slip and we are not sure who
has sent this to you we're looking into
this but if you have any clues as to who
might have sent this to you
parenthesis any name mentioned let us
know if we if you have any questions
please email us at love allah thank you
how high would that be if he [ __ ]
goes they sent him to prison I think
that long-ass thing she just read could
have been like we've never been to the
moon there's no bleep fraud because he
used their logo so Josh in his video he
ended up telling like the Space Center
like hey sorry guys like I used your
image and all this but this is a lot of
great exposure you have to pay for that
[ __ ] what did this kind of right I love
the rock inside of a crack bag crack bag
there was a jar there are little vials
last jar jar what is your mind that
looked like from this angle that looks
like a crack back oh I see how you could
it look flattened yeah yeah I see is it
crack baguette or yeah looks pretty
convincing is it crack bag in a weed bag
the same bag yeah doesn't it look like
it if you look like after suggesting
yeah then my mind can make it look like
it because the top part you know where
the cap is yeah looks it looks like the
zipper put yeah I think if you sent that
thing to every single person
Erica you would trick about 70% yeah
probably I'm one of them yeah oh I would
just if I'm looking for content I just
want to do anything rare and unusual and
if I get a [ __ ] moon rock I'll be
like would it melt with magma you know
physical item two it's not just like
someone's sending a letter like you've
been selected it's like oh they said a
thing yeah exactly it's more convincing
yeah yeah I mean he sent this to
different types of influencers like some
of them only had like a hundred thousand
or like ten thousand tens of thousands
of followers or other ones had like 2.2
million followers so these are people
liking you and some of them even
hand-delivered to their place magician
come into play that's why I told you I'm
like I don't know why that's relevant
they gave me that information so I'm
gonna give it to you maybe help
orchestrate having magicians there
they're known for being able to
construct like a false reality to make
you believe in certain things so he's
probably like tapping into a person
psychologies like what would make
someone want to post it so he's probably
like the letterhead or gotta put in the
charge kind of look legit the serial
number maybe there's like two points a
good magician yeah or three points of
authenticity to make people really
confirm it I only like Penn & Teller
everyone knows to me are weird I like
what's the name David Blaine little card
tricks on street looking look in your
shoe if you go to their show they like
destroy Street magic and he's like oh
they like kind of like show all the
tricks of street magic yeah it was maybe
it was too close and I could see like
the fish thing you saw
yeah there's clearly a [ __ ] mirror
and I'm like oh come on and it was like
split I'm like man why would they even
have this [ __ ] turned her brain off I
tried but they [ __ ] put it in my face
yeah you got the wrong angle you could
see everything and it sucks magic show
for my birthday cuz I love magic even
though he just shadow magicians well I
mean magicians are [ __ ] creepy by
love magic
and then we went to one
this guy he was like making this girl
float and you can clearly see there's a
metal rod that's going down here but I
turn I told my brain to turn it off I'm
like wow it's always super simple when
you've never the trick is revealed it's
always so mesmerized by the magician and
you get his birthday I was like how are
you doing this [ __ ] cuz I had a whole
stack of cards and he was able to move
him on like there's magnets huh he's
like no it's like you know why I think
magicians are weird
they like magicians they they're like
porn is to watch how intellectually
superior they are to people or whatever
[ __ ] face yeah they like the reaction
they're like you didn't know what I just
did
Stephen I mean to a magician at Gina's
birthday party I feel so bad for him
yeah he did it in jest he was like I was
just [ __ ] around everyone was
laughing kidding I was like yeah but
this guy is the butt of the joke so it
was a magician at Tina's birthday party
I was watching from afar like on one
side I like this guy's loose but anyone
that does [ __ ] magic tricks at a
party is something's wrong with you do
it at a [ __ ] stage we'll also unless
somebody asked like oh you do magic cool
show us if you're the one going up two
people will be like you want to be
mesmerized [ __ ] out of here man yeah he
wants to it was just what type of person
he was was like kind of more like like
he was passionate about it and he was
all it's like more timid you go to a pot
look and so much just has a random deck
of cards you're like what the [ __ ] I
understand that means you always had it
in your pot yeah dude I was at a club in
Beijing and then this fat old dude was
trying to do magic tricks to impress
girls inside the party and I was like
what the [ __ ] is this guy wait that's a
girl but not into getting her to sleep
how is the magician carrying cards
different from a guy in a corner [ __ ]
practicing karate I don't get it wait
neither should work Geo
neither one these powers are built-in
okay and I'm not trying to impress
anyone
I don't do karate I'm fun to keep what
if he's just practicing this no you're
practicing we realize you just talked
about yeah I go off in my own corner do
my own karate I don't think you do court
corner karate
[Music]
[Music]